first yeah it is October 1st very soon
students will be back in the classrooms
and older Canadians will return to work
from summer vacation but more time
indoors could bring an increase in
transmission of covid and other viruses
with new sub-variants circulating you
may be wondering when is the best time
to get a booster shot a bioethicist says
Canadians need health advice from the
officials that led us through the
pandemic now I do understand this is not
2020.
having said that I think we're getting
an incredible lack of clarity as to what
should occur the country's National
vaccine advisory committee has said
there will be updated boosters targeting
the latest variants in the fall but
Health Canada hasn't said when they'll
be available to Canadians this doctor is
hoping for a rise not a wave in cases
but says that depends on the shots being
available My Hope Is that's going to
happen in September if it happens in
September that might that that could
help us really stem the tide most people
can get one of the Jabs available now
but if you want a new one you'll need to
wait the advisory committee says booster
doses need to be at least six months
after your last shot or infection
whichever is later if you're not at
higher risk this epidemiologist says
hold off for now I think uh waiting for
that new formulation of the poster dose
um in the fall will be the way to go
because
um you know because they already have
enough immunity Health Canada told
Global News approval and availability
depends on many factors luadrin says
Canadians need the new formulations as
soon as possible because any covert
infection is still serious and
hospitalizations are Rising once again
Nathaniel Dove Global News